peu
[Musique]
[Rires]
si elle enlève son poète
elle est à moi
[Musique]
une calèche dans la nuit sur une route
de campagne
quelque part entre angoulême et pas au
mois de septembre
1827 un enlèvement mais on leur demande
comment madame la comtesse a pu en
arriver là
cette histoire a commencé il y a
quelques semaines un après midi de
printemps dans le salon de la conteste
deux barges temps là maïs l'a décidé
ainsi
c'est un impair plus que cela une faute
il faut la convaincre de l'éviter c'est
impossible
qu'est ce que c'est possible le sheikh
nice ne me dites pas que c'est vrai
qu'est ce qui est vrai ou pas vrai ma
chérie il paraît que vous voulez donner
une soirée pour ce petit poète quand
avez vous déjà le chardon et sardo et
que vous avez l'intention de le
présenter à la société chez vous
assurément j'ai distingué monsieur
chardon il sera un jour la gloire de son
pays
je suis sûr que tout ce que j'estime
l'honorons comme je veux le faire
ses toiles est le gazon volonté
voici lucien lucia chardon
lucien est le fils d'un pharmacien qui
s'est ruiné à la recherche d'un
médicament miracle qui devait faire la
fortune de sa famille un rêveur disaient
les gens il est mort en laissant des
dettes et deux enfants à élever à sa
femme madame chardon est une demoiselle
de rus bat après pas lutter mais pour un
destin plus haut mais sans courage et sa
dignité égale son infortune elle s'est
mise à travailler pour faire vivre ses
enfants elle garde les malades les
femmes en couche
sa fille lui ressemble eve sans rougir à
accepter sa position pour aider aux
ressources de la famille elle repasse le
linge chez une blanchisseuse le sort m'a
condamné
lucien est le dieu de cette femme toute
leur foi toutes leurs espérances repose
dans ce fils dans ce frère adoré leur
dévouement à son avenir
elle sent pas comme celui de david ses
chars un ami de collage imprimeur son
travail il partage ses maigres
ressources avec lucien qu'il a engagées
mais lucien ne veut être capable pied
des cons à mon secret c'est bourg lucien
c'est très beau il faut continuer je
crois en toi
nous croyons tous sans toi merci david
mhirsi sera notre gloire le plus grand
poète de son corps n'est ce pas monsieur
ses chats quand il aura réussi
il vous rendra au centuple vaut bien
fait le sien ne me doit rien que de vous
rendre heureux et fier vous et madame
votre mère
lucia se rappellera toujours que votre
amitié à sauver vous êtes tout mon
bonheur tout ce que j'aime
je vous promets de n'oubliez jamais on
tour viendra de vous donner la joie je
réussirai paris sera mes pieds j'aurais
j'aurai la gloire et la fortune pour
vous plus que pour moi pour moi
l'émotion que je vois dans vos yeux
quand quand je l'aimé pas et me suffit
je je n'aurai pas besoin d'autres
victoires
mais je veux m'imposer pour te rendre
d'avis de l'argent que tu me donnes
chaque mois je sais que je ne le mérite
pas que que je suis une charge pour toi
mais je veux réussir pour vous arracher
toutes les deux à ces travaux qui sont
ils sont indignes de vous je veux que la
gloire ma mère vous redonne le droit de
porter bien haut notre nom de rue après
leur one n'accordera nouveau aussi si je
fais preuve de ma valeur eve tué posera
david si si je le veux je te donnerai et
toi david toi david jeu je te
commanditerait tural la plus belle
imprimerie du royaume maman et j'ai
confiance
croyez moi tous grâce à moi nous serons
heureux
pourquoi bonsoir il se lance postale la
santé va toujours en bien merci
comment peut-on choisir une vie qui se
passe tu t'en tires avant d'en découdre
des potions et les en place du sien ton
père est pharmacien
oh mon père n'avait rien à postel
c'était un savant un chercheur
il voulait être un piaf et heures de
l'humanité il est mort à la tâche mon
père aurait été 30 à lucien tu es un peu
être regarde j'ai reçu ce livre de paris
je devais apporter les poésies d'andré
chez elles viennent d'être éditées aux
nuits douloureuse au toit tardive aurore
bien tu vas tu venir
es tu bien loin encore
david slade désespérante beauté je ne
saurai jamais voilà tu es tout entier
dans cette réaction
tut exalté tu te décourages aussitôt
prend garde du sien je te parle on aime
vous ferez des abattements face aux
dures réalités me font peur ne peut pas
connaître mes tourments
c'est cela un peu vrai tristement
[Musique]
sans doute je n'ai pas l'âme aussi fia
que la tienne mais je crois à
l'opiniâtreté y aller fort soutenu
je crois que dans ce livre il ya aussi
beaucoup de travail tu veux être un
savant la ville si peu ce que tu ne sais
pas encore tu peux la prendre
les ouvrages existent qui t'a porteront
ce que tu désires mais ce que je ne sais
pas moi c'est la vie tu comprends la vie
il faudrait vivre j'étouffe ici je suis
perdu sans espoir dans cette misérable
ville c'est le monde entier qui renferme
ce que je ne sais pas partir du conte
pense il me faudrait partir
tiens une réception tu le savais
oui
lucien
qu'y at il
aimerais-tu madame de bach chopin
éperdument mais savez vous sur maïs que
ce petit poète a pour mère une femme qui
gardait il ya deux mois ma belle soeur
en couches qui est-il d'extraordinaire à
ceux ci c'est une demoiselle de rubin
près elle est d'excellente famille et
j'ai bel estime pour son courage mettons
nous à sa place que ferions nous pour
vivre sans un sou vaillant et comment
améliorer vous nourrir vos enfants on
peut s'intéresser la fortune des gens
sans pour autant de recevoir dans son
salon monsieur châtelet mes ancêtres et
leur ego ont toujours admis dans leur
salon les gens de mérite et de talent
bien rarement les employés de l'état qui
n'avait pas d'autres titres à leur bonne
comme je savais que je vous ferai écrire
nar s'attend score du côté du zoo
quoi qu'il en soit j'ai décidé d'aider à
la carrière de ce jeune poète je le
recevrai dont je suis sûr qu aucun de
ceux qui m'aiment ne voudra manquer à
cette soirée
j'en serai très fâché c'est une créature
merveilleuse elle m'a reçu d'abord comme
une grande dame
elle voulait protéger le jeune écrivain
dont le recteur lui avait parlé peu à
peu nos rapports ont changé nous sommes
ouverts l'un à l'autre
j'étais émerveillé elle est isolée dans
la mesquinerie de son entourage comme je
suis dans la pauvreté c'est cela qui
nous a réunis
nos deux solitudes et l'amour de la
beauté près d'elle j'entrevois ce
pourquoi je suis fait la noblesse des
sentiments le raffinement des manières
le luxe
je souffre tellement de mon état
misérable
je crains
tous vous sépare le monde les préjugés
tu es bien jeune cette femme a déjà vécu
mais tais toi elle même je le sens elle
est aussi jeune que moi puisqu'elle n'a
pas encore émis
as-tu des preuves de son sentiment
d'épreuve mais tu ne peux pas savoir
tout ce qu'elle veut faire pour moi
m'imposer à sa société
malgré la sottise les préjugés de tous
ces gens elle veut que je sois son
oeuvre
elle veut faire ma fortune elle veut ma
réussite elle veut faire front à mes
côtés ce ne sont pas des preuves cela
ses cheveux
alors il semble folle de lui valide tête
mon cher elle protège l'artiste voilà
tout elle a entendu dire que les
candidats magie c'est de la sorte à
paris l'artiste est bien intéressant je
lis dans vos pensées vous amuser à
m'aider pour chacun ici me fait sentir
ma disgrâce mais je ne suis pas homme à
laisser rire de moi il est vrai que le
roi mais exilé dans cette province
j'ai eu le tort de plaire aux maîtres
précédent mais rappelez-vous que
napoléon s'y connaissait en sommes
écoutez moi bien j'ai fait toutes mes
classes et j'ai appris le monde
je connais la vie et ses intrigues
j'ai mon but madame de bargeton ce sera
à voir la soumission de cette odieuse
petite reine de province sera ma
première urgence et nous verrons la
suite
entrée je vous dérange pas du tout
j'avertis monsieur chardon de la soirée
que nous allons donner pour lui le
monsieur de bargeton adore et admirent
sa femme silencieusement
il ne dit jamais rien rien peut-être
désirez vous écrire vous même monsieur
chardot aux non rendu
un modèle un modèle chantons la santé
pas sur nick si j'ai une lettre pour
votre frère on a apporté tout à l'heure
il n'y avait personne chez vous un
laquais de l'hôtel dar jetons vous êtes
dit l'imam
j'ai beaucoup d'amis fier si je pouvais
m
la suède a lieu après demain vous
entendez après demain elle veut
m'imposer à tout seul elle marche sur
tous les obstacles sur toutes les
oppositions surtout les préjugés mais ne
faut-il pas qu'elle m'aime beaucoup
voilà c'est le départ la première marche
de mon ascension je suis sûr
je suis sûr maintenant nous allons être
tous heureux moi nous aimer comment
pouvez vous croire cela si vous me
connaissez cette femme et mon âge mon
bonhomme david geoffrion nous triomphons
lee lice si les vrais le préfet le
général tout ce qui compte dans la ville
c'est bien lui suivre tout le monde et
stains et le vôtre se joue dans cette
soirée
mon dieu que vais-je me mettre à mon
affaire ne t'inquiète pas puisque ni
vous ni elle ni moi ne sommes invités
chez madame de barges temps oui vous
venir passer la soirée avec le monsieur
david s'il fait beau vous me promènerai
le long de la charente nous causeront de
notre grande
j'ai entendu dire votre locataire
le petit chardon s'en va dans le grand
monde ce soir
il paraît qu'il a plein de choses dans
la tête ce garçon je ne sais pas s'il en
a plein la tête comme vous dites mais je
ne crois pas qu'il va grand chose il
coûte de l'argent office c'est cher et
il ne sera pas un primeur je ne sais pas
s'il sera poète et je me demande ce
qu'il va coûter à madame de bach jetons
ici à laisser à bâbord
[Musique]
où
justin justin
annoncé monsieur chardon bien monsieur
monsieur chardon
monsieur
oh
j'arrive le pont digue
c'est assez naturel
madame de barges ton s'habille sans
doute oui elle s'habille
j'ai remarqué que les personnes qui
habitent loin arrive toujours plus tôt
que celles qui demeurent près oui je les
remarques et de même à quoi cela
tient-il je ne sais pas
terreur dans la vie de monsieur rarement
monsieur le baron du châtelet bonsoir
mon cher bon soir bonsoir
je suis bien content de pouvoir vous
connaissez monsieur chars dont on nous
parle beaucoup de lui
et qu'y at il de nouveau voyons mais le
nouveau c c'est monsieur chardon
précisément et ça nous change un peu si
vous êtes notre poète et nous allons
entendre des verts de votre façon quel
genre j'ai apporté les poèmes d'andré
chénier gens n'iraient quelques-uns les
verts sont trop indignes d'un public
aussi connaisseur
dommage oui dommage car si son ramage
ressemble à son plumage
n'est ce pas oui oui oui monsieur
chardon est un très beau jeune homme
mais trop modeste trop modeste
un avis que je prendrais de vous pour un
concert monsieur chardon à la répartie
ne trouvez vous vous étiez là les
premiers parce que les plus impatients
je suis heureuse monsieur j'espère que
cette soirée le sera pour vous comment
foutu
monsieur vous êtes parisien que
pensez-vous les bateaux allaient tu vois
pas votre toilette je vous regarde
madame laissez moi mon admiration
ouais vous croire tout à fait mais cela
est agréable à entendre m'admirer vous
aussi merci mon dieu madame vous savez
bien comment vous dire moi vous êtes oui
vous êtes une récompense et nous savons
que nous méritons pas très grandes
heures monseigneur l'évêque monsieur le
préfet et madame le barreau et la parole
de rastignac mademoiselle ou lors de
rastan toi un comte et la comtesse de
chant tour
quelle soirée
oui l'air est à la fois tiède et frais
les fleurs embaume le ciel et magnifie
enfin demain il fera beau c'est bien
cela n'est ce pas vous êtes bien
silencieux vous savez vous allez finir
par mme embarrassé je veux croire que
cette promenade vous en dit pourquoi ne
dites-vous rien je vous dis pas que je
suis
aïe
vous êtes fait mal maintenant ce n'est
rien vous n'êtes pas trop fatigué voulez
vous que nous retournions non mais c'est
moi m'appuyer sur votre bras jeu mais
difficile on me guiderait
je suis né pour l'amour j'ai connu ces
travaux mais certes sans mesure il m'a
câble de meaux a porté ce revers mon âme
est impuissante et quoi beauté divine
incomparable amante
je vous paie quoi par vous nos liens
sont rompus vous le voulez adieu vous ne
me verrez plus du besoin de tromper ma
fuite vous délivre je vais loin de vos
yeux ici il verrait le dit ni s'arrête
la digestion
[Rires]
continuez monsieur de rubin près je vous
en prie mais vous faites toujours
larbitre de mon sort
déjà vous prévoyez vous annoncer ma
fermer les yeux oui notre écran penas on
ne perd point vos charmes
[Rires]
à connaître vous là pour voir couler mes
larmes pour connaître mon coeur vaut
faire vos cruauté tout l'amour qu'ils
m'en braz et que vous méritez pourtant
que faut-il faire
les
on dit je crois qu aisément de vos
traits on bannit la mémoire que
jusqu'ici vos braz inconstant et les
jets ont reçu 1000 amant comme moi
passagers charbon doute que l'ennui de
vous perdre ou mon âme succombe nadeau
qu'un malheureux accélérer la tombe
comme j'ai pu vous plaire et comme vous
lasser de vous comme mon coeur je
pourrais me passer
superbe merci monsieur merci j'ai fort
bien réclamer mais j'aime mieux le oui
ça vaut vous devez avoir soir et vous
tous également mais je vous en priver
les parisiens passent aux à côtés il dit
très bien les voeux n'est pas mon avis
ne jamais me l'aviez naturellement vous
m'avez d'enchanter me semble que les
autres les autres n'existent pas mia
mois
ce
ce que fait-il en ce moment
vous la connaissez vous cette femme non
c'est un monde qu'il n'accepterait pas
la porte n de lucien ne peut se faire
que dans ce milieu n'est ce pas écoutez
moi les chiens m'inquiète il ne faut pas
que je vous le cache
mais je les aime beaucoup vous le sentez
bien je vais beaucoup étudié le sien est
faible et il manque de persévérance il
aime les récoltes sont à peine qu'elle
demande
il m a brillé et le succès de soutien
que dans la solitude dans le travail
obstiné le clinquant des salons vallée
bleue weir et cette femme va s'amuser de
lui comme d'un jouet mon enfant vous me
ferez extrêmement plaisir
vous essaierez d'un prix ne peut pas
refuser
sur la mauvaise grâce eh bien merci
je me suis laissé dire que la mère de ce
jeune homme comme femme du plus au
mérite
elles aident pas ils le travail de son
fils pendant de longs de veille en
faisant des lectures de prêts va vous
dira de ses poèmes
à de ses poèmes et monseigneur les
blacks
reprenez vos places il plaire du cerveau
à elle
du sein de ces torrents de gloire et de
lumière comme l'éclair jaillit hors de
la main de dieu il est si fier mais je
travaillerai ma mère et moi nous
travaillerons nous y permettront
d'attendre le moment que sa fortune
commencera à vos voitures et cela ne
suffira pas vous voulez me désespère et
vous aidons à faux amis en on aime vous
le savez laissez-moi vous aider
laissez-moi devenir le frère de lucien
je n'ai pas sa grâce je n'ai pas son
génie mais je suis volontaire si vous
l'acceptez je travaillerai pour nous
tous
pour lui il faut qu'il aille à paris là
seulement il trouvera des compétences
qui apprécieront son talent il faut de
l'argent beaucoup plus d'argent que
celui que vous pourrez lui envoyer alors
que si vous me laissez l'espoir de
travailler pour lui
le soutiendrons et variées il pourra
s'imposer
voulez-vous et il n'y a pas une amitié
qui mérite un tel sacrifice
de leurs pieds lumineux montrerait le
passage comme un phare éternel espère
tous à ceux des mouvements
ce sont des verts comme nous en avons
tous plus ou moins faire en sortant du
collège semble tellement son poète n'est
qu'un ouvrier dont la mère est garde
malade et la soeur blanchisseuse la
dette obscures mais la déclaration est
claire bailly s'est tout de même
croyez vous le père était apathique
il aurait dû donner aux fils des pilules
[Musique]
mais il y brille des souffrances je vis
de mon cher enfant toutes vos épreuves
passées et celles qui vous appelle
monsieur m'appelait tous les mérites de
bonne famille
je suis bien de relire un poète
c'est un élu de dieu monseigneur votre
bonté réchauffe mon coeur et que nous
préparez vous un recueil de sonné sur
les fleurs sur les fleurs curieux
travaillez-vous âge
pourquoi pour avoir l'esprit plus léger
les verts de 8 pieds sont les meilleurs
pour que n'ont plus cours la vraie
poésie française monsieur c'est la
chanson certaines sont très jeunes et
très utile monsieur avec une bonne
chanson on entraîne le soldat où l'on
veut faites vous des chances
je n'ai pas ce talent vous n'auriez pas
au moins une tragédie en tête
non non j'écris un roman historique sur
le règne de charles ix 9 c'est un
véritable travail d'érudition amis mais
je me suis beaucoup documenté
j'ai eu de très nombreux ouvrages de
soir chez moi et tout ça dans cette
seule tête
c'est un sujet qu'il me faudra méditer
bien longtemps votre accouchement sera
difficile votre excellente mère pourra
vous aider à ce qu'on m'a dit excusez
moi mon seigneur
il
il ne faut plus que votre mère continue
ce travail pénible je ne veux plus vous
soyez une ouvriers vous êtes digne d'un
sort mieux
m
je vous ai 16
accepter de m'épouser pour l'amour des
membres plus tard peut-être
arriverez-vous à mai mais en voyant les
efforts que je fais pour servir d'autres
offrir et pour rendre heureux mais mais
vous un buzz
seulement 20 noeuds
mais je n'ai jamais pensé un autre homme
que vous
ou pas
je triompherait
je triompherait jeu les écrase raymond
mais briller j'aime à vous voir cette
détermination
oui vous triompherez j'en suis certaine
et je vous aiderai avez vous songé que
ces gens là sont tout ma compagnie
depuis des années moi aussi j'ai tout
près d'eux il faut partir par dur nous
partons cher fois l'aîné
il faut faire bon visage
[Applaudissements]
évidemment pouvait pas songer à prendre
un parapluie ne pleuvait pas tout à
l'heure monsieur vous êtes bien je
pourrais vous dire des banalités en
forme de morale par exemple que je garde
toujours un pas puis à compter de la
main car j'ai appris comme le temps que
c'est la terreur pigments je crois que
vous voudriez de memories parabole vous
pouvez me dire les choses honnêtement
avait du talent de monsieur vous êtes
jeune et vous est agréable à regarder on
d'arguments entraîne la sympathie
beaucoup de ce fait vous avez la mienne
toute la nuit c'est elle qui m'a si
comme prévu la société ce soir et et
impertinente à votre égard ne se ferait
pas ces gens n'ont aucune importance
mais on vous a montré par ailleurs d'un
sentiment qui pourrait vous trompez ne
vous exalté pas non plus
une fièvre de tête avec les mouvements
du caire vous serez cette différence
quand vous aurez très content des
[ __ ]
en attendant je m'offre à vous la dire
chaque fois qu'il en sera besoin pour
éviter les déceptions bien dangereux via
minutes
je profiterai de cette info tant que la
croix de votre part des intéressés
c'est que vous ne redoutez pas exact
encore moins
ou pas
le chemin est bien mon disque avec elle
par djokovic
aussi
pour me pardonner de ne pas vous laisser
mon parapluie ce soir il c'est bon
monsieur
on est tous les mahorais réseaux d'avis
ne rien mais qui est in du sien c'est
une soirée merveilleuse sais pas si vous
avez trouvé cette soirée rebelles vous
avez été cruelle pour moi les brutes des
ganaches comme ils sont les perfides
murray ah c'est ça le monde se sont
moqués ils m'ont bafoués eh bien je
terminerai ce monde orgueilleux puisque
de par ce ton était allongé pousserait
madame de barton s'est lui dans ses yeux
ce soir l amour et galons bien sera ma
revanche il ne trahira jamais pardonnez
moi mais que s'est il passé
eve et moi nous nous sommes fiancés
tu ne comprendront pas david m'a demandé
de l'épouser et j'ai accepté avec
bonheur mon dieu
mais
mais c'est merveilleux ainsi à fos tu en
as trouvé un autre que moi pour le faire
souffrir à mon frère nous lutterons
simple oui
voilà les accordailles des gens pauvres
vous avez du courage mon enfant car nous
sommes dans le malheur je tremble qu'il
ne soit contagieux il faut avoir
confiance
pour commencer vous ne ferez plus votre
métier de garde malade et vous viendrez
demeurer avec lucien la maison d'écouté
voici mes projets d'installation je vais
faire surélevé d'un étage ma maison pour
le récit risque d'être long la liqueur
de cassis allez un salon maman on vit
des réserves et faisons la fête toute la
nuit j'ai cherché du tabac j'ai vu tant
l'air tout à l'heure quand tu invites
annoncé la nouvelle
pourquoi
s'il conteste de bargeton consentait à
devenir madame lucien de rubempré jamais
je ne voudrais être la belle-soeur de ta
vie de ces chers aux monty c'est une
récompense et non restauré et david
bennett était moi évidemment alors david
cette installation mais sérieusement
ok mon cher vous n'avez pas de chance
c'est ainsi votre adresse elle convainc
tout ce que vous visez vous à charenton
il ne faut pas courir deux lièvres à la
fois chasse pourchasse je préfère
l'affût et croyez moi je suis sûr de ne
pas rater ce que je dis
dans les jours qui suivent il n'est
question dans toutes angoulême que de la
soirée chez madame de bargeton les
moindres événement en sont si bien
dénaturer augmenté embellie de lucien
devient le héros du moment
[Musique]
là pour voir couler mais l'arbre
pourquoi notre manque que lisez-vous des
poèmes de chénier marraine petit set
mon ami faites-moi à pareille fête
lucie madame de bargeton sont-ils les
coupables pur
telle est la question on en parle
partout swing autres en politique pour
faire 89 la barre jetons c'est la
bastille il faut la prendre c'est un
trait des petites villes que les
réputations sont faites et défaites sur
des qu'en dira t'on
[Musique]
lucien depuis la grande soirée a ses
entrées à l'hôtel bar jetons chaque jour
il fait maintenant sa visite monsieur
duchâtelet comme il l'a dit est à
l'affût il attend son heure
[Musique]
pour une fois n'y va pas accompagnez
nous david à une surprise pour toi
l'appartement est prêt il ya un bureau
pour toi david l'a voulue à toute force
et l'acte écrira t chef-d'oeuvre ne pas
surveiller mais pas raisonnable à vie
crois-tu qu'elles soient raisonnables de
consentir à m'épouser
j'ai fait notre maison aussi belle que
j'ai pu tu entends notre maison je serai
une charge pour nous en tétouan travail
prennent nous nous serons heures merci
david hâle on vient lucien tu peux bien
pour une fois nous préférer à ta
comtesse doit l'avoir pour une affaire
sérieuse
danse
à ce soir
a tout de suite je passerai peut-être en
sortant d'une telle de barges temps on
me dit ah si tu peux
je suis désolé il me pose allait régler
sur l'heure à un différend avec un
fermier
non mais je vous en prie madame de
barges temps est chez elle elle serait
désolé que vous les fassiez défaut vous
ne m'en voudrez pas pour une fois de ne
pas être là
laissant seuls leurs de monsieur
duchâtelet est peut-être venu
monsieur barbu au japon à me demander à
monsieur le comte s'il peut m'accorder
restant l'entretien ce monsieur le comte
vient de sortir monsieur le baron je ne
pense pas que monsieur le comte revienne
avant ce soir france fhf s'est fâché je
vais prévenir madame la comtesse
non non non je vais faire monsieur le
comte il n'est pas là je me retire
martin qu'est ce que c'est
monsieur duchâtelet désiré par là
monsieur le comte il est reparti très
bien mais l'excellent cette porte
ouverte
ainsi voudrais jamais que nous restions
salah moment cela ne se peut pas mon ami
songez-vous nous sommes et comment
pourrais-je d'oublier un instant un seul
instant ça nous à l'hôtel bargeton nous
sommes chez votre mari nous sommes au
milieu de grosjean faut donc que vous ne
receviez dans votre hôtel avec votre
mari près de vous par extraordinaire il
n'est pas là aujourd'hui c'est la
première fois n'était pas vrai la
première fois j'ai faut que les portes
restent ouvertes aux jambes voix pour
que la ville entière vois que je suis
seulement un bien gentil peut être que
l'on reçoit pour les les mérites de son
esprit
pardonnez moi je m'emporte
je vous fais des reproches ne
seriez-vous pas encore la vérité de mon
sentiment
ne sentez vous pas que personne jamais
part à plus de respect pour vous sera
plus soucieux de votre honneur
votre dignité comment oserait jamais un
geste une parole qui vous blesse
je veux bien que vous ne savez pas
comment je vous aime je veux bien que
vous ne m'aimez pas
si cette porte ouverte est la cause de
votre abattement oui non
madame la comtesse a appelé oui veuillez
m'apporter un mouchoir je vous prie
vous venez d'être impertinent le sien
mais je vous excuse
vous venez d'être injuste aussi hélas ma
peine restent vives
ainsi je ne vous aime pas comme c'est
mal toute cette vigilance pour vous
guider toute cette tendresse pour vous
soutenir
toute cette émotion pour vous admirez
tout cela ce n'est rien ce n'est pas
l'amitié la plus haute qu'une femme
comme moi puissent voyez un jeune homme
comme vous mais que désirez-vous de plus
quelle autre preuve qu'ils ne soient
dégradantes pour l'âme vous et moi nous
sommes différents du commun voudriez
vous que nous abaissions à agir si
communément pardon
enfants chers enfants
nadège pas donné un gage de notre union
tout pur mais si forte
louise personne d'autre que toi n'a
utilisé ce prénom il est pour toi tout
seul
que demander de plus la confiance toute
confiance soit alors nessma fermer cette
porte comme preuve seulement comme
preuve de cette confiance tout neuf j'ai
quelque chose à vous confier qui ne
souffre pas d'être surpris par une autre
que vous
voilà mon ami
[Applaudissements]
confidences à vous faire et elle est
bien lourde tuer d'entrer tout prix
occuper tout à l'heure est grave
ma soeur va se marier elle épouse david
ses chars garçon merveilleux mais
n'allez vous pas trouvé cette alliance
un ding de ma destinée si le roi un zoom
a fait un nouveau compte de rubempré est
pauvre lucien et la peur d'être grande
et mais où est le mal et que me fais ta
famille où tu fais une exception
je t'aime le ciel c'est là tout ce qui
compte
soit grand sache conquérir la gloire
je serai près de toi
oui non taga sont tout de même de ne pas
savoir avoir comme le jeune homme porte
beau dans toute la ville
moi je dis que c'est oui dambach je
tournais pas coupable parce qu'ils sont
petits prés de fait un peu le vaniteux
il est tout fier d'être reçu dans un
monde ne croyait jamais entré voilà tout
vivid un peu de chocolat ma beauté
l'outil puisqu'il est de la parole
merci en tout cas je vous dis nice en a
positivement la tête tournée et je suis
son ami j'ai pu l'observer la tête la
tête si ça ne sent pas plus bas
françoise cette conversation n'est pas
pour vous allez à l'église dira chapelet
nous prendrons en sortant bien marraine
non je ne crois rien de ce que vous
croyez
et cela pour deux raisons comme il est
amusant pour deux raisons voyons
monsieur le résonnèrent vient d'une part
et je vous mets de côté les sentiments
personnels destine que j'ai pour m
je tiens ma dame des barjots d'autres
passionnés de son mérite pour la croire
capable de s'amouracher de rim ailleurs
l'esprit pour avoir d'essence
deuxièmement je tiens que dans une ville
comme la nôtre tous examinent tous
rapporte une faute est à vous et où elle
est impossible c'est vrai comment
pourrait-il la nuit une cape une calèche
les bois ils ne sont jamais seuls le
barge temps et là il ne dit rien mais il
ne sait pas comment on recommence
il voudrait d'une s'ennuie tellement
mais comment pourtant aujourd'hui j'ai
vu sortir juste au moment où le petit
chardon arriver ouais ils ont fait ça y
est moi je vous assure que madame de
barges t'en ailles otayo il faut y aller
voir enfin mon ami mais les domestiques
restait que les domestiques givet sur le
premier non mais si on vous demande que
je dirais que j'ai trouvé la porte au
maire je suis une amie de la maison vous
savez surtout attendez moi tous vous ne
bougez pas non mais je vous accompagne
mais je vous préviens 12 ans et pour les
fans votre imagination tombait pas
quand je t'ai rencontrée j'ai su que tu
étais toute la poésie que mon arme avait
enfin trouvé une âme qui lui ressemble
songes mon ami que je vis ici depuis dix
ans entourée de ses médiocres qu'ils
n'ont pas compris l'autre soir si tu
avais vu ton visage pendant que tu
lisais tes yeux étincelants
je sentais la chaleur de ton fronde de
des mains
le monde ne m'épargnera pas plus qu'il
ne te paraît comme ces lampes toutes ces
années que l'on n'a pas vécu
je serais content vincent manniez je
suis que pour vous retenir
encore une fois les italiens mais s'il
n'ya pas de mal ici mon linge est
innocent novembre sous la peau morose
mon cher on s'amuse
comment vous ont bien pu s'échapper
la noria mais on va semble tout à
l'heure cette porte était ouverte
le boulot et non mais je me trompe
peut-être
j'ai maintenant vous frapperez je vous
demandais pourquoi d'abord n'ya sûrement
personne
et puis c'est une pièce où j'ai
l'habitude d'entrer sans façon pour
entendre oui mais je ne trouve pas ça
correct moi je préfère vous attend
vendeur on va refaire
traité comme un enfant ne savait pas
plus cruel pour un homme que vous
n'aimeriez pas le croiser
louis
je renouvelle je reviens qui est venu
monsieur de chant duo madame si nous a
vu ainsi perdu tant mieux eh bien vous
voulez que je vous dise cela est bien
triste persuadé que stanislas c'est trop
peu je vous répète que j'ai vu vu ce qui
s'appelle vue c'est la dernière que
j'avais su je passe chili croyez vous
qu'il faille le dire un peu plus tôt ou
un peu plus tard
alors je préfère en parler tout de suite
se déformerait moi la vérité alors mon
ami venu
cette histoire me bouleverse et puis il
faut que nous passions françoise à saint
pierre je ne peux pas cacher son vicaire
il est mieux que nos amis apprennent
cette histoire discrètement
je vais prévenir valable à confesse
si je vous ai demandé de me recevoir à
cette heure c'est que l'affairé est
importante
je vous en prie
vous savez sans doute déjà ce dans toute
la ville s'occupe pas du tout je suis
trop votre ami pour vous laisser ignorer
le singe de chant d'où est venu chez
vous cet après midi je l'attendais de
rares je les ai vus revenir effaré il
prétend vous avoir vu avec monsieur de
rubempré dans une situation qui ne lui
permettait pas d'entrer
j'ai voulu revenir sur le champ avec lui
ici pour éclaircir ce qui ne pouvait
être qu'une erreur mais il était si
agitée qui m'a entraîné maintenant que
stanislas et d'une travers qu'ils aient
raison il faut qu'il est à ne laisser
pas jouer votre vie votre honneur votre
avenir pour un saut imposer le silence à
l'instant je vous suis entièrement
dévouée disposer d'une vie qui vous
appartient si le petit rhume après a
fait une folie le serai glorieux d'être
votre défenseur l'honneur d'une femme
serait être à la merci du premier tour
dit qu'ils se mettent à ses pieds
disposer de moi je vous le répète
merci
que comptez vous faire
je verrai
mais vous aimez dont temps ce petit
rubin près
bonsoir
venez mon cher j'ai à vous parler
monsieur vous me connaissez vous me
connaissez bien
cet après midi monsieur de rubin prêt
était ici à mes genoux il me faisait des
confidences de jeunes hommes avec ardeur
avec exaltation avec quelques
exagérations
je l'écoutais vous savez combien je me
suis intéressé à son sort stanislas est
entré au moment où je relevais cet
enfant au mépris des devoirs que la
courtoisie impose un gentilhomme
il a prétendu dans la ville entièrement
par surprise dans une situation
équivoque je n'ai pas besoin de vous
dire que votre femme est pure à lézat
l'instant chez stanislas demandez-lui
sérieusement raison des propos
insultants qu'il a tenus sur moi ne
souffrez pas que la sphère s'arrange à
moi qu'il ne se rétracte en présence de
témoins nombreuses est important que
vous conduirez en homme d'esprit en
galante homme vous aurez droit à mon
estime bien voilà comme j'aime que l'on
soit vous êtes un gentilhomme
je me dis enfin c'est pas possible j'ai
mal vu voyez le tableau alors j'ouvre un
peu plus la porte
monsieur le comte de bargeton comme ces
thèmes abl
je suis heureuse de voir merci merci
vous voulez parler un stanislas
oui
allez dans la chambre à coucher de
mairie
merci
oui
alors venez mais pourquoi qu'est ce
qu'il veut m'enfin stanislas à suppose
et après midi au bout c'est une
plaisanterie mais après tout qu'est ce
que j'ai vu je leur disais vous tous les
deux hommes d'honneur vous prétendez
monsieur va retrouver madame de barges
sont dans une situation équivoque avec
moi je reviendrai monsieur chardon soit
si vous ne démentait pas ses propos
devant la société que chez vous ce soir
je vous prierais de prendre un témoin
mon beau père monsieur [ __ ] policière
et vous cherchez à 4 heures du matin la
sphère ne peut s'arranger que la façon
que je viens d'indiquer je suis le
français je choisis le pistolet
c'est bon
à demain
ils vont sûrement se battre sans doute
oui il ya longtemps je vais pas parler
sinon comment
du sien il ne faut surtout pas que tu
sortes
mais pourquoi des amis de monsieur de
chant dur pourrait te provoque et moi
monsieur de barges toi monsieur deux
champions se sont battu en duel ce matin
très tôt dans la clairière désormais y
monsieur de nègrepelisse a déclaré un
monsieur de change jour que s'il
arrivait malheur à son gendre il se
chargerait de le venger
on avait choisi un officier de cavalerie
pour arbitre monsieur de barges ton
semble être là comme pour une promenade
c'est un homme de la campagne à qui j'ai
entendu raconter l'histoire
il était dans son champ il a tout vu
on a compté 25 pas au signal monsieur
bargeton a tiré le premier
il a logé une balle dans le cou de
monsieur de chant ndour qui est tombée
sans pouvoir riposter
un chirurgien arrêter l'hémorragie mais
il paraît que monsieur le champ du
aurora le coup le travers pour le reste
de ses jours
on dit partout que tu es la véritable
cause du duel mais je vous assure ma
mère je ne sais rien quoi qu'il en soit
ne sort pas le mariage de ta soeur aura
lieu après demain il faut éviter un
scandale je t'en supplie je venais un
valet de l'hôtel bargeton m'a donné à la
banque ce billet venez ne vous montrez
pas
soyez prudents
il va pas sans jeter sur à moussy un peu
c'est après demain le chien elle
m'appelle je parle
je vais à paris et mon père quand même
monsieur de bargeton chez lui le tuer le
comprenez oblige à fermer cette maison
je vais d'appareils siens ma cousine la
marquise d'espagne est en ce moment très
influente je veux profiter de ses
faveurs j'ai pensé à vous nous n'avons
pas cherché cet éclat mais j'y vois le
signe que nous fait le destin il faut
que vous le compreniez il faut partir
aussi vous accompagnerez n'est ce pas oh
pas réussi à te rends tu compte
la haye la vie des gens supérieur ne
laisse pas ton talent s'étioler en
province il faut que tu rencontres des
pères que tu échanges d idées que tu
donnes que tu reçoives que tu t'es pas
nouis la haute société seul peut te
mettre en valeur je vous ferai recevoir
j'ai la marquise despars ou personne
n'entre facilement vous ne rencontrerez
chez elle que le haut personnage le
ministre les ambassadeurs les paires les
plus influents les gens riches et
célèbres égéries que vous souhaitez des
galets qui grand talent non pas du petit
s il vous prêteront leur appui vous
aurez mais l'occasion de fortune une
pension que le roi vous accordera il est
à protéger les arts
vous allez vivre lucien je parle cette
nuit la journée suffira aux préparatifs
vous m'aurez précédé je vous retrouverai
au relais de mansle garder le plus
profonds secrets
eh bien vous ne voulez pas
sur ce maria pas demain
très bien monsieur
je crois que je me suis trompé
pour vous j'envoie ce matin mon mari se
battre en duel pour vous je ferme ma
maison je m'exile je veux à paris pour
vous profiter de mon crédit de mes
parents de mes relations
et vous me préférait un repas de noces
c'est mal
ici même vous ne juriez à des moments
sans pardon alors dans la louise je
viendrai je viens c'est bien sûr je
viens vous aurez à vous faire pardonner
une aussi grave hésitation chaque jour
je vous demanderais pardon soyez discret
et trouvez vous à minuit à une centaine
de pas après mende le chemise fine et
600 grosse toile soigne bien ton avis il
est un peu fatigué je t'aime' ici
mouchoirs mais tu n'as qu'un pantalon
nankin est seulement de gillet mettable
là c'est parfait
qui va s'occuper de ton l'âge là bas
c'est elle qu'on soit prêté les mille
francs mais seulement pour six mois et
pas à toi il veut la signature de david
il m'a dit que tu ne faut qu'une
garantie bien je m'en passerais nous
avons donné tout ce que nous avions lui
ciel ça ne te fait même pas un écu par
jour c'était possible tu ne pourras pas
vie nous verrons elle venait
je ne veux pas décider cela tout seul
nous allons nous marier les dépenses que
j'ai fait pour notre installation
absorber tout ce que je possédais si je
souscris ce biya postel nous commençons
notre vie sans argent et avec la menace
de cette dette
mais lucien est un frère miens nommément
voilà
le somme de dix mois dans la vie agit
selon ton coeur je penserai toujours
comme toi
elle est dire à monsieur postel que je
consens donné ma signature je joue pas
trop mal je sais ce que je veux que tu
as tous mais attendait le résultat et
vous saurez combien je vous aime comme
mieux je pense à votre bonheur non mais
tu ne sera même pas mon mariage
si jamais oublier cette scène tussauds
le dernier défi
sur la haute après le relèvement soit tu
le sais lucien tu peux toujours compter
sur monde car j'ai bien peur que tout ce
que tu as promis cette femme de 30 ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parti ils sont partis ensemble et paris
est au bout de la rue les voeux les plus
ardents se réalise enfin
mais cet enlèvement au fait le quai dans
la ville autre arrêt bien maussade
lucien le coeur serré
remords pour ce qu'il laisse angoisse de
l'avenir
madame de barges temps est inquiète
n'at-elle pas fait la une de ces folies
irréparable
il
s'ils pouvaient se parler se confier se
rassurer mais ils ne sont même pas seul
[Musique]
c'est paris qui a été toi enfin son
toute cette histoire ne me dit rien qui
vaille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et cochez ralentit c'est un peu il ya
une voiture devant nous je ne veux pas
l'attraper avant paris au prix de
seulement
[Musique]
quand